hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play paranoia
I'm just kidding all right so we're
immediately running away from this guy
because as you know we left off that we
had to like do something hide in a
fireplace great idea okay so anyway we
just got back into paranoia can yeah
thank you I'll get back to you oh that
one killed me oh come on there are only
two hiding places that could have killed
me I actually um found a picture in the
in the game folder that shows all the
hiding locations not where you're
supposed to survive apparently but just
all the possible ones so I'm going to
use that as a reference for where I need
to go and that's obviously not correct I
need to run really quickly right now
okay so that was obviously the not one I
don't think there's another one in here
so I just kind of got a kind of got a
gooo
I got a go I gotta go now um there's one
in this bathroom here in this closet
over here
gonna kill me gonna get me okay okay
alright
what the hell is going on
am i surviving here
okay no thank you I don't want any of
that
what oh oh I survived that's so weird
that I did that okay well why is it
morning yes it is congratulations did I
fall asleep um possibly the things gone
good it's gone forever can I leave this
house now no let's let's eat a meal even
though I woke up in a dresser in the
bathroom nothing normal happened a dream
but it felt too real and did wake up in
a dresser yes you realize all these
things that are bad that you need to
maybe take care of oh shut up nurse get
back to you in a second I'm doing very
important game recording for all my
constituent fans constituent fans
constituents fans for all you lovely
people out there who are so beautiful
and amazing you all are awesome so now
I'm gonna try to leave this cursed house
and get the hell out of here forever and
ever and ever and ever
no reason to go out how about every
reason to go out what are you talking
about what are you talking about
whatever this girl is dum dum dum okay I
got a key which means that I probably
got to find out where it goes who hello
alrighty then some pretty flowers okie
dokie anything special about those
flowers there's something here that I
need to know about probably in that old
well hello an empty well no nothing okay
alright I don't see anything out here
probably something for later in the game
but I gotta find where this key goes I'm
guessing it's one of the upstairs rooms
which were locked there's a whole bunch
of them to the left here it's got to be
one of these hello I don't know do I
wait hang on do I actually have to use
the key I don't know haha there we go
okay got it
alright we're okay Elroy oh this looks
fancy face lotions expensive looking
cosmetics brand clothes
do like a lot of these large dresser hmm
in the drawer a note why gotta be so
loud all beauty all beautiful things are
fake beauty is there to hide something
you talkin about my beautiful face that
needs to hide something well too bad cuz
I'm not robbed I'm not ripping off of
this thing cuz it's just to press right
everybody's just I'm too amazing ok
anyway gaudy pink nice color so
something in this room is too beautiful
and is hiding something or something in
the house is too beautiful and it's
trying to hide something I'm getting
bony well it's obviously not me because
I'm a stick figure anorexic girl
whatever ok brand necklaces who cares
perfumes ok there nothing here that is
there nothing here that would help me in
this endeavor what does the note say
again ok all beautiful things are fake
beauty is there to hide something so
this is obviously a clue there's
something in the house that is beautiful
that is hiding something
I'm guessing it's a mirror but at the
same time hang on I don't have another
key I didn't get another key besides
that note
wait hang on let me check um me check
this room again because when I was in
there before it was very dark ok this
stain of blood maybe ok there's nothing
oh this mirror here no can't do anything
with this mirror
ok that was wrong someone was over here
sea bed on the ground calendar another
mirror here
nothing Sasha's socks kimono yukata
whatever that means down here flocked
yes PS alright um okay
all right I didn't need to solve a clue
I just need to answer the phone maybe I
can save that clue for later when
something reveals itself hello taka
Maura revered a residents whose is it's
miss taka Maura it's hi oh god Hayakawa
how's your condition no real progress
but it's not getting worse either I see
I see and so you move did you not I've
been in aquaria before if it's very nice
quiet grace it should be a good place to
relax either way I talked with the
editor about the binding I'll fax it to
you tonight please do I then man such
abrupt phone conversations here he sure
sounds a tease wish I could be too but
I'm writing romance novels I do not want
to write well why are you writing them
then okay so now got all that taken care
of can I leave this house ow can I
please go home please no reason to go
out maybe there was something in the
backyard
those flowers were pretty are those the
fake it's some pretty flowers
no okay ah these are artificial big time
oh the beautiful things are fake I put
two and two together
I'm though JJ's house my a Chianti why
did you bury this here wait a minute
just a key how is it am I just gonna get
a slew of Keys randomly throughout this
game and I'll have to go hunt and find
where the hell they go to I'm guessing
it's another door upstairs I don't think
there are any locked doors downstairs
ker-chug ker-chug and winner winner by
simple process of elimination it's what
it has to be okay brooms and dustpans
brooms and dustpans boxes thingies song
e's shavers and such Oh another key how
good for me for what room well I could
only guess there's only two left
uh-huh
haja Oh how's it locked how they both
locked wait a minute
doesn't make any sense was there another
locked room around here no this one
opened up last night what about this one
what was this one was this another
bathroom okay this is just another
bathroom
hang on wait a minute let me just
double-check everything nothing inside
okay
all right never mind then really that's
not the case was there one over here
click on the bottom no but there is a
locked door and this one oh come on
where the hell could it be what could it
go to there's no other locked doors is
there is there yeah maybe one of these
on the bottom maybe this on the bottom
here no yes where's the last lock door
have no idea well is one of these like
was this locked but that not at whoa
what the hell is going on maybe this is
a safe password password SAE ki it
opened another key god damn it another
key holy crap what the hell why your
obsession Keys okay is it to this door
no no but then I've got a key that
doesn't go to any door what if I splits
wait was this one wasn't this one
oh that's there's another bathroom how
many damn bathrooms does this place have
okay so this has got to be a key to one
of these doors over here I have to have
one oh come on
both of these ones are unlocked this
one's a dressing room and this one's the
storage room I've got two keys which
means that one has to go on the other
side of this one or else I'm gonna blow
my brains out with a shovel gonna [ __ ]
it like it's game okay this ski is for
here what is in this room Oh
welcome pootron hello locked with a
password which is s AEK I know okay
apparently not all right half drank
water bottles TV I don't know where I
could find a code but I haven't gotten
another note yet so I'm assuming that's
gonna be the clue for me but what I need
to do
I have a key I need to save us what I
need to do I have this cute no I did it
again I got Isis sorry sorry everybody
okay I have a somewhere key that goes
somewhere where whoa no whoa no at the
doorbell huh hello oh hi oh hello this
is mr. Kumar's house yes who are you
I'm Shinji me Yura from across the
street it seems Amos delivered your
luggage to me oh sorry to trouble you
well I already stamped for it did
delivered a person didn't even seem to
notice Oh little egged rather heavy if
you let me and I'll carry it for you
uh-huh no no you should do it shouldn't
I can carry it myself please don't worry
about me I'm used to physical labor oh
well all right you like to eat accents
that I'm doing I just kind of I kind of
ease myself into the accents after a
while there you go madam okay I can just
put it here here oh yes thank you very
much I wish I could thank you in some
way oh how about some tea some hot tea
oh you do that for me very well then
this guy's talking so creepily or maybe
it's just me maybe it's my voice said
I'm attributing to his dialogue so
you're a rat I miss Doug amaura that's
mean I'm not that great I like to read
real literature but I have no talent can
only write these stupid romance novels
no don't say that
I can respect anyone who makes a living
from ridin so what are you doing here
all alone it's only for a lot of reason
but I can't keep that up but mainly for
recuperation recuperation you mean from
an illness yes but it's not that Syria
the impre-- homes previous owner it's
empty I saw him living here are you
referring to messiah key you knew
her yes she was my aunt she thoughts
away now oh I'm sorry for your loss but
your mistake he's nice I still don't
know how pronounce that you don't look
much like her huh [ __ ] really my
relatives always said I did I her
well mistake he was rather odd you see
how odd was she how odd was she don't
get the wrong idea but she would scream
oddly and wander at night she was quite
well-known here maybe she was running
from monsters in the middle of the
darkness she was mentally ill I'm sorry
on her behalf no no I'm sorry for
bringing it up see here we go I should
be going thank you for the tea no wait
the bedrooms right upstairs oh so
handsome
I I'm on leave for an injured arm and
then I made you carry all those boxes on
an injured arm how dare I call me if you
need anything it may be hard for a young
woman to live alone in these parts but
I'm sure you'll be fine running from the
monsters hey wait a minute on second
thought you kind of look like that
monster hmm you're pixelated version not
the drawing version well you're right
I'm not used to it I might ask you if I
need help thanks for your concern
ring-ring after chasing me ah you're
just as crazy as your on-click that'll
be the end of that he seemed friendly
alrighty then I'll sort out that luggage
now if you say so
lady I'm sure a monster won't come
crashing after you that sure took a
while it's gotten so late I'll take a
shower and sleep maybe shower not good
idea that that didn't lead to good
things last time don't do it please
don't please for the love of the
children
Oh Oh boys out at this hour mr. Hayakawa
isn't it he shouldn't call this late it
looks like a booty cook huh huh Hey
okay shut up I get it I get it the
phones ringing hang on
hang on I get it I get it I'll get it
I'll get it just shut up just shut shut
your face your face needs to shut your
face needs to be quiet just be quiet
with your face that is not appropriate
midnight behavior it's not gonna be mr.
Hayakawa is it mr. Hayakawa I presume
I'll tell him a thing or two
hey listen here young man
holy crap
what oh that was really freaky
oh sorry everybody
go run I agree I agree profusely okay
hang on I got a consult my girl
installed by hiding-place bed - where
are my clothes - uh-uh I was just in the
kitchen where oh my god dad okay I've
got think the bathroom is not the
appropriate location to hide again that
would probably kill me probably probably
very seriously kill me ah he fell fast
he's so fast
uh-huh okay a new SH I'm gonna try the
fireplace this time it got me killed
last time hopefully it won't be about
that run
god damnit Oh God
ah not here sir somewhere else okay let
me get some distance and then save no
okay so the next time we start this it's
gonna be a running start again ah I got
me okay so anyway I hope you're enjoying
the same I actually really am enjoying
this game it's very cool and when I put
my mind to the puzzles the puzzles make
total sense like I really just got lucky
that I looked at the flower before I got
that last puzzle so I'm hoping that what
I need to do is I need to like go
through the hell house and like look at
everything so that I know what it's
referring to when I find it so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for videos that I've done
if you doubt - this game is scary
playing for yourself it's really creepy
and I really like it I mean these these
RPG horror games that's how much
potential it is really cool that they do
so try for yourself thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye oh
yes okay good um nurse twenty-seven cc's
of Hydra Morga flourish bourbon please
haha here's the other heart yep just
where I expected it to be
and drag that into place faucet oh no
where the heart go whatever go put my
heart no where to go okay um people all
notice you won't notice because this guy
is now gonna have em up on a crazy face
oh god oh god what am I guess that I'm a
fraud
I got a fraud